and it's zoken who comes up with the answer oh
was top but forsberg R's going to have multiple
saves of the Year trouble Robertson
hold back to hint GL save Arison Sam
Arison says oh no you don't left-handed
larsy and we play on what a save here by
Aron go here's Hughes in a l trying to
settle in and it's zoken who comes up
with the answer oh wow Jack Hughes one
of the best players in the game had all
the time in the world but he didn't have
the move to beat ilas sroi cross the ice
Sean thers snaps one tip down rebound it's
soken another Sensational save that time on
Bastion Dro that left pad down and big save
late in this second period is sliding across
pad down flat I mean talk about about
the ability to be able to flex those
legs on his horse The Greenway cutting
the outside back to Tops oh what a stop
up forsberg stretching up the glove to
Rob Thompson on the doorstep and he's
able to rip this out of the air that's a big
[Music] save three onone opportunity for the
Blue Jackets Line pass it great sh marru wow as
he robs vantilly looking for his first NHL goal
the 18-year-old cannot believe it what a stop I
can't believe it texier into the Minnesota Zone
deceivers across and what a save by guson
a sliding stop by the Minnesota golender
Minnesota takes the lead and then gustofson
saves the day with a blocker save it's 32
wild the out here comes brat mat Phil brat on the
puck and there's an across shot what a stop Pat
denied by Primo get serious what a stop welcome
back to the NHL and he is bringing it for the
Bell Center crowd on their feet early here all
five guys going back to him spectacular stop
backing at the line Brer out L it's a pass great
save to sterin absolutely loves colan looking for
a second of the game somehow it's still just
one nothing that was a terrific stop by the
Rangers goal Pender as the Flames looked like
they had their second from our angle up here
it looked like just a wide open net now zorov
takes a look shoots and that a try great sa's
jerk and another robbery off timately this time
as he got the right Pat out how did he make that
stop and open and dising what time
how did that St stay out Campell
an unbelievable save and it's still
32 it's like a Superman save right
there he just Dove back and denied
on a beautiful shot pass by capris
off Rin will Ser it blacking it across the
ice but K it shoots and how did that not
go in I think it went off the paddle of Soka
well it's just the fourth game of the season
in net for ilot sokin and he just continues
to make plays like this well he's going to
have multiple saves of the year in the in
the National Hockey League and there's one
with the paddle just stays right with it he's
got the patience never gives up on it McKinnon
over ran it slips it in front and the toe
of sokin kept it out I think Ross Colton
thought it was in guys it certainly wasn't
but he's pointed to the net what a save by
sokin he can't believe it that it was an empty
net but sokin again as he so often does found a
way for Fetti across Dylan has ru shot
Z Thompson rebound and what a stop on
Peretti Thompson went back across to his
left and a strong first period for Logan
Thompson of the Vegas snap highlight real
save there as he robs Peretti extends to the
pad the stick and it hits his stick early
candidate for the save of the year right
there BRS it across the line Michael tow Dr shot
sa the rebound oh another sa made by Carter Hart
he stuck the glove out and robbed eel on the
rebound two beauties from Carter har great
shot great opportunity heart with not one but two
great saves on eel right back and Over The Line
opportunity here cutting behind the net with
a W and stopped unreal save by Connor Ingram
and I thought this was going to be automatic
I thought he had him but look at the push here
by Ingram Oh there boy they've got it going on
top of the crease to c s now on n n just stoed
Again by Joey dor that chance can't happen but
it did and your goenda you out oh what a that's
Dynamite wow by Joey dord and rste toward the
net whipped It Wide on the reload here's Nets
off turned aside by a sprawling wall and re
put it white cuz Nets off with a chance and
Wall comes across and takes that away that
hopped over the Stick of graen point it's
fr the blows down oh what a stop did you see
that off C to keep it tied a brilliant stop
by Joseph wall oh boy H sends it down L sent
AC cross bumper Bunning with a Chance Second
Chance rebounds there gorv oh three big saves
gorv showing why he's been a storyline for the
Avalanche at the start of the year there's one
shot by bunny here comes a second there's a tow
drag and a third that last one was the most
dangerous there's a shot the rebound s kov
and it bounc him underneath him somehow kov kep
that leg down and kept it out of the net I got a
chance to see what happened K jov thought he was
scooping the puff to his body with his catching
glove then he scooped it right out through now
cder right in pass great save bar off Savannah
J robs him in tight watch this little feet
cder's going to get it that is a fantastic
save